he's underway early most days
several times a month javier ramirez
climbs the takanaw volcano on behalf of
iucn
the world's biggest environmental
organization
everything he encounters on his way up
fascinates him
it's the interaction of the different
species that make for this special
variety
starting with the animals the fungi the
bacteria and the plants
every day the volcano is shrouded in
clouds that cover the surrounding trees
and other plants
the clouds keep the ground moist and the
air humid
farmer frantisco ortiz owns land up here
that he got from the state
together with the conservationist he's
building barriers of old tree trunks to
protect deforested slopes from erosion
nature means everything to us because we
live from it
that's why it's important to us to
protect it
is on a slope of the volcano at an
altitude of 1700 meters
the people here live exclusively from
growing coffee
at this altitude coffee beans are more
aromatic earning more money for the
farmers
to protect his coffee plants and the
soil francisco ortiz has switched to
organic fertilizer
the organic fertilizer makes the coffee
plants stronger
where to use chemicals my plants would
perhaps thrive for a year or two but
then they'd die
the organic fertilizer makes my plants
more robust
but the farmers still can't prevent
disease from attacking their plants
diseases like the fungus known as coffee
rust or la roya
eventually this leaf will turn
completely yellow and die the entire
coffee plant will dry out and no longer
produce beans
many farmers on takanawa have switched
to sustainable farming without chemicals
like letizia flores who sells her
flowers at an organic market in
kakawatan
as part of an iucn initiative what's
good for nature is useful for the
farmers
the market is an additional source of
income for them
we come here to sell what little we have
to increase our income
and pay for school for our children
it's important for javier ramirez that
farmers benefit from environmental
protection
for them the fertile soil around takana
remains their most important resource
and they want to keep it that way for a
long time to come